[Music]
so
[Music]
i just woke up and uh
so tired
i'm gonna make some
some breakfast
nowadays i have to get up a lot earlier
than before i have to sometimes make
early morning chinatown trips
and sometimes our earliest deliveries
are around 11 o'clock
quarantine days man it's got me going a
little crazy
right now i'm enjoying my coffee i mean
i usually get up late later
because you know only time i can
actually wake up late is uh
around this time so
and catching up with all my emails it's
monday the 30th as you can see the
streets are pretty empty
we all worry about this pandemic i'm
sure that
will pass and we'll come out stronger
out of it so it's been
two weeks since we decided to close the
restaurant people have been donating uh
via vemmo to our account
and we've been taking that money and
essentially making bentos and donating
them to healthcare professionals
throughout
new york city for the bentos we prep
them today for delivery tomorrow
it's better when it's cold because then
the doctors nurses and health
professionals they pop it in the
microwave
the reason why i told you because it's
like i wanted to talk about the takeout
stuff for now i don't know i'm not even
sure if the takeout option is good for
us i've been talking to some people and
definitely take out and delivery helps
for some some it's not even worth it
more than half of our appetizers we
don't serve to take up you know they
contain raw fish um so
they won't have that full jeju noodle
bar experience people are
getting uh
jumped or beat up you know because the
fact that they're asian what is your
thought about that the risk is like
beyond great although we have to be
mindful of the business as well right i
don't know what's the right or wrong
answer
i think we do have some time to outweigh
the pros and cons all right i just want
to check up with you stay safe
manchester united
like i do every morning i check on the
qualities of everything we do i will go
over our counter for all the pastries so
first i check on what we call the cross
section
so all the cutouts for the vinosy to
make sure the quality is good we have a
lot of
our friends
in
the healthcare community and we're gonna
do some charitable donation for them for
the team to make sure we can support as
much as we can
so one hospital needs 55 bentos and
another hospital needs 50. these were
all made yesterday
some more here
and we have some more here
beverage coolers are now
bento coolers we started at what 70
bentos a day
now today we're doing 250 yes
[Music]
let us know if you need more all right
any time
see these guys are always super nice
[Music]
all right we just opened the shop a few
minutes ago now we are doing some prep
one of the morning preps actually our
pivot x and which which is right here
it's a strange time it reminds me a lot
of when we first opened the bakery we
see some people from the neighborhood
coming um to get some bread to get some
you know hey and it's nice to see the
community
it's nice to be here for them it's nice
to be
a part of something a little different
going to the restaurant right now
empty restaurant empty restaurant
checking make sure everything is all
right make sure i don't smell gas and
things like that you know because you
know once the restaurant is not operated
anymore
uh it tends to like break down very fast
i don't know what what causes it at the
other day this is our home so it's very
very important to check every day
back
at the restaurant the staff is actually
already
cooking chicken legs raising
two woks check it out
this huge stockpot the
cabbage
curry in the making and we got some
potatoes carrots all this broccoli 90
cups of rice
we have got
the production line going and these guys
are rock stars
yeah we
ready for the next round
right now i'm sitting at the empty
restaurant and make me feel very sad we
used to do almost a 150 to 200 covers
every day
but now everything went back to zero we
took so much effort and energy to build
this place and
it was so fortunate to have this kind of
you know establishment i personally have
to file unemployment myself
anything will help this at the moment i
wish i can get something my goal is make
sure we have a place to come back after
this disaster goes away
we need that hope
i'm getting ready to pack an order for
in front of us
at the hospital we're very thankful for
um everything they do for us at the
hospital and want to make sure that we
can give back as much as we can so i've
prepared some dka right here this is the
quinya man i'm gonna put this in the box
for them and they'll have it for
breakfast tomorrow morning
we just had a call not so long ago
talking about a
thousand dollar donation which is 100
bentos throughout the entire morning
while we were doing delivery donations
have been coming in and we keep very
close track of it
this is literally from the very first
donation to the very last
this morning we've received
52 individual donations
pretty overwhelmed by the support and
love i'm gonna see drew's advice he's
like legendary uh restaurant tour from
new york city he owns a nobu uh he owns
the tribeca grill he always gave me
important advice for me i'm gonna ask
him you know some other question my
concern and what his perspective is long
time no see
you're good you're good right so i have
to wear masks you know quarantine so
what is like a lot of big restaurants
what are they how do you how they're
going to survive is that
the way i see it we spend money three
ways
rent food
labor reopening is going to be a big
hardship because when we reopen
there's no guarantee all of our staff is
good the guy like you yeah
i feel the most for because you have a
small restaurant that's
unbelievably popular
doing good business
how could you see this coming
yeah i've had a mask on for the past
almost six hours it's definitely taking
a toll i don't know how the healthcare
professionals do it all the doctors
nurses and all these guys do it i'm
actually in chinatown right now for a
quick errand this is all the groceries i
need for two days chicken we have napa
cabbage
we have some shaoxing wine and
vegetables in here
guys at the supermarket is working very
very hard around the clock a 15-minute
minute errand or like a grocery run is
now turning into
something that would take an hour and a
half just got back to the restaurant
and boom
we are restocked
for tomorrow
food production is about done for the
day some more laptop work
logistics organizing uh
little more donations organizing and
a lot of social media stuff so andy is
back here
in his cubicle
i'm gonna be sitting in my cubicle
right now it's about a little after five
last thing i need to do is drop off the
check to the post office
so everybody needs to get paid i'm
walking back home
crossing union square
and it's funny because they have all
these markers on the floor people want
to keep distance
from each other six feet
at a time like this when
almost nobody is working my staff is
able to come in uh they're still getting
paid well it's pretty amazing
we're very fortunate to still have
something to do we used to do on a busy
day about like 250 covers
and now we do zero
just to arrive home and after gathering
all this information from other people
and you know
talking with the drew today uh i think
it's the situation is going to get worse
employees and myself
safety is more important and you know
that delivery pickup service so
at the moment i don't think i'm gonna
open up uh delivery and pick up for next
week i just got home a little bit ago
and i have some uh sperry cooking right
here
inside
here
spare ribs with five spice a little bit
of rock sugar just want something quick
easy nutritious probably gonna catch up
on a little bit more work do some more
social media stuff for for 886
and probably a very solid hour of video
games yeah that's the plan for the rest
of the day i'm gonna make uh pasta with
leek that should be very quick and
simple dish
you're gonna enjoy
if you're stressed out you always need
ice cream it's not good for you but it
releases your stress
so
i'm in a special room right now uh
i'm gonna be a father soon so i'm
getting uh ready
to build this beautiful room for my
little boy coming soon i have
all this stuff here getting ready i'm
pretty excited about it and at least
it's a good news with everything's
happening now
currently 10 30 at night trying our best
to stay busy again we're very lucky that
we are busy i know a lot of people think
that we have more time
with this virus but it's not true for
everybody and actually there's a lot
less of us so it's actually more work it
is a very tough situation i don't think
you're gonna do the take out delivery
options
uh
for me i think is this this is a way too
dangerous
for our employee at the moment and i
feel very guilty if somebody gets it i
see a lot of chefs
doing a lot of great things for the
community for
hospitals helping out i'm sure i'm other
chefs on another restaurant tour they
have to stay open and i really respect
that i wish all the best and they can
succeed and making a better
situation for them so hopefully we can
feed more front liners and
help people
pay their staff hopefully get back to
normal very soon let's go through this
together thanks for tuning in
[Music]
you